STEVE: MUST-SEE TV.
PETE, THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
LET’S DIAL IN LARA TRUMP FOX
NEWS CONTRIBUTOR NOT FAR FROM
MYRTLE BEACH.
GOOD MORNING TO YOU, LARA.
>> GOOD MORNING.
I’M FROM WRIGHTSVILLE BEACH,
NORTH CAROLINA.
IT’S A BEAUTIFUL TIME OF YEAR
DOWN THERE.
STEVE: INDEED.
LARA, WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THE
FACT THAT NOW THE PENTAGON IS
GOING YEAH, GENERAL MILLEY
CALLED HIS COUNTERPART IN CHINA
TO WARN HIM THAT IF YOU’RE
UNSTABLE FATHER-IN-LAW TRIED TO
START A WAR, HE WOULD STOP IT.
DID GENERAL MILLEY STAB YOUR
FATHER-IN-LAW IN THE BACK?
>> IT CERTAINLY APPEARS THAT
WAY, STEVE.
AND I STRUGGLE TO FIND ANOTHER
WAY TO SEE THIS, QUITE FRANKLY.
WE NOW HAVE, WITHIN THE SPAN OF
A LITTLE OVER A WEEK, TWO PHONE
CALLS THAT WE LEARNED ABOUT.
ONE FROM JOE BIDEN TO THE AFGHAN
PRESIDENT AND NOW MARK MILLEY
THAT WOULD HAVE CERTAINLY
RESULTED IN AN IMPEACHMENT FOR
DONALD TRUMP AND, YET, I GUESS
WE HAVE FORGOTTEN NOW ABOUT THE
PHONE CALL JOE BIDEN HAD WE’RE
JUST DONE WITH THAT ONE.
NOW WE SEE THAT OBVIOUSLY THIS
WAS INSUBORDINATE.
OBVIOUSLY THE CHAIN OF COMMAND
WAS BROKEN.
THIS BORDERS ON TREASON.
I KNOW SOME PEOPLE HAVE SAID
THIS IS A TREASONOUS ACT.
IT DOESN’T MATTER, GUYS, WHETHER
OR NOT YOU LIKE THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES, WHETHER YOU
AGREE WITH HIM POLITICALLY.
THAT IS THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
THAT IS THE COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF.
AND THAT IS THE INDIVIDUAL THAT
CALLS THE SHOTS AND NEEDS TO
KNOW ABOUT PHONE CALLS LIKE
THIS.
YES, WE ARE FINDING OUT THERE
WERE MORE PEOPLE THAT WERE
INVOLVED.
BUT IF THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES HIMSELF DID NOT
KNOW THAT THAT IS A BIG PROBLEM.
BRIAN: DO YOU THINK, EVIDENTLY
THAT GAP PERIOD BETWEEN THE
ELECTION DAY AND JANUARY 20TH,
THE INAUGURATION DAY, THE
PRESIDENT WAS INCENSED A LOT OF
THE TIME.
IN FACT, THIS IS WHAT ONE QUOTE
WAS ABOUT GENERAL MILLEY.
HE SAYS HE FEARED TRUMP WAS
SUFFERING SERIOUS MENTAL
DECLINE.
HOW WOULD YOU CHARACTERIZE THE
FORMER PRESIDENT DURING THAT
PERIOD?
>> WELL, THAT IS AN ABSURD
REFLECTION OF WHAT ACTUALLY
HAPPENED.
WHEN YOU HAVE A VERY
QUESTIONABLE ELECTION RESULT AND
YOU DON’T GET RESULTS FOR QUITE
SOME TIME, I THINK YOU PROBABLY
WOULD BE A LITTLE UPSET AS WELL.
MY FATHER-IN-LAW, WHEN HE WAS
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES, HAD COMPLETE AND TOTAL
CONTROL OF EVERYTHING.
BY THE WAY, YOU CONTRAST HOW HE
ACTED AS PRESIDENT VERSUS JOE
BIDEN, AT LEAST THE WORLD KNEW
THAT WE WERE SERIOUS.
AT LEAST WE WEREN’T BEING
LAUGHED AT AT LEAST WE WEREN’T
GETTING 13 SERVICE MEMBERS
KILLED OVER IN AFGHANISTAN WHILE
DONALD TRUMP WAS IN OFFICE.
SO, I THINK IT’S A RIDICULOUS
ASSESSMENT.
I’M NOT SURPRISED THAT THAT IS
THE CHARACTERIZATION OF SOMEBODY
THAT DOESN’T LIKE HIM.
BUT I THINK WE ALL KNOW THAT
THAT WAS NOT THE CASE.
AINSLEY: ACCORDING TO THIS BOOK
"PERIL" NOT ONLY DID MILLEY HAVE
THIS CALL WITH CHINA TELLING
THEM IF WE’RE GOING TO ATTACK
YOU I WILL LET YOU KNOW IN
ADVANCE.
THEY’RE ALSO SAYING THAT NANCY
PELOSI CALLED MILLEY COMMANDING
THE NUCLEAR FOOTBALL BE TAKEN
AWAY FROM YOUR FATHER-IN-LAW
DURING THIS TIME PERIOD.
AND MILLEY SUMMONED HIS SENIOR
OFFICIALS AND TOLD HIM THAT HE
MUST BE INVOLVED IN ANY DECISION
TO LAUNCH A NUCLEAR WEAPON.
AND, IF THAT’S THE CASE, IS THAT
COLLUSION?
THIS IS WHAT CHRIS MILLER, HE’S
THE FORMER ACTING SECRETARY OF
DEFENSE, HE SAYS:  I DID NOT
AUTHORIZE THESE CALLS WITH
CHINA.
THAT’S A VIOLATION OF DUTY.
HE SAID PURSUIT OF PARTISAN
POLITICS AND INDIVIDUAL
SELF-INTEREST ARE A VIOLATION OF
AN OFFICER’S SACRED DUTY.
AND HAVE NO PLACE IN THE UNITED
STATES MILITARY.
A LESSER RANKING OFFICER ACCUSED
OF SUCH BEHAVIOR WOULD
IMMEDIATELY BE RELIEVED OF DUTY
PENDING A THOROUGH AND
INDEPENDENT INVESTIGATION.
AS SECRETARY OF DEFENSE, I DID
NOT AND WOULD NOT EVER AUTHORIZE
SUCH CONDUCT.
SO, IF THERE IS AN
INVESTIGATION, AND IF IT’S TRUE,
YOUR FATHER-IN-LAW IS ACCUSING
HIM OF TREASON, THE REPUBLICANS
ARE DEMANDING THAT MILLEY
RESIGN.
WILL HE RESIGN?
DO YOU THINK HE SHOULD?
>> I DON’T KNOW WHETHER OR NOT
HE WILL RESIGN.
I THINK THIS IS YET ANOTHER
EMBARRASSMENT FOR AMERICA AND I
THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE WOULD LIKE
TO SEE HIM RESIGN.
I THINK AT THE VERY LEAST WE
COULD ASK THAT WE GET SOME
ANSWERS FROM HIM THAT HE -- WE
HEAR IN A CONGRESSIONAL SETTING
EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENED HERE.
WE CERTAINLY WANT TO GET THE
TRANSCRIPTS, THE FULL
TRANSCRIPTS FROM THIS CALL.
AND I’M CURIOUS, WAS NANCY
PELOSI SWORN IN AS PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES?
AND NONE OF US KNEW?
MAYBE SHE OUGHT TO ANSWER SOME
QUESTIONS, TOO.
IT’S A REAL DEBACLE AND QUITE A
MESS RIGHT NOW.
I HOPE WE CAN GET THIS SORTED
OUT AND I HOPE IT’S NOT LIKE
EVERYTHING ELSE THAT HAS
HAPPENED UNDER JOE BIDEN WHERE
WE JUST SWEEP IT UNDER THE RUG.
STEVE: WELL, IT’S IMPOSSIBLE TO
SWEEP UNDER THE RUG, LARA,
WHAT’S HAPPENING ON OUR SOUTHERN
BORDER.
YOU KNOW, WE SHOWED FOLKS A
MOMENT AGO AN IMAGE OF 7,000
MIGRANTS UNDER A BRIDGE WAITING.
AND LOOK AT THIS.
IT’S A PICTURE OF A 2-YEAR-OLD
GIRL AND HER 3-MONTH-OLD BABY
BROTHER.
SOMEBODY ABANDONED THEM DOWN
NEAR DEL RIO, TEXAS.
JUST, YOU KNOW, WAITING FOR THE
AMERICANS TO COME AND SAVE THEIR
LIVES.
IT’S JUST HEART BREAKING.
AND THEN YOU LOOK AT THE BRIDGE
WITH 7,000 PEOPLE UNDERNEATH.
THEY’RE JUST WAITING TO BE
APPREHENDED AND NOW THE NEWS IS
APPARENTLY THE ADMINISTRATION IN
THEIR WISDOM HAS DECIDED OKAY,
IF YOU ARE A MIGRANT AND YOU ARE
COMING INTO THE COUNTRY, WE NEED
TO VACCINATE YOU, GIVE YOU AT
LEAST ONE SHOT.
BUT ONLY IF YOU DO IT LEGALLY.
IF YOU ARE ILLEGAL, DO YOU KNOW
WHAT?
YOU ARE NOT GOING TO GET A SHOT.
>> I MEAN, I JUST WONDER
SOMETIMES HOW DUMB DO THEY THINK
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE?
WHAT YOU JUST DESCRIBED THERE IS
ABSURD.
THE FACT THAT WE HAVE A FULLY
OPEN SOUTHERN BORDER, THAT
PEOPLE CAN JUST COME ON OVER IN
ANY WAY THEY WANT, THEY DON’T
NEED TO BE VACCINATED, I WAS
WATCHING THE SHOW EARLIER WHEN
IT WAS DESCRIBED EXACTLY HOW
THIS HAND HAPPENS.
THEY COME OVER AND THEN THEY ARE
TRANSPORTED ALL ACROSS THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
THEY ARE NOT TESTED FOR COVID.
THEY ARE NOT VACCINATED.
BUT BACK TO THAT PHOTO OF THE
2-YEAR-OLD AND THE 3 MONTH OLD,
MY DAUGHTER, CAROLINA JUST
TURNED 2 LAST MONTH.
THIS IS A HORRIFYING THING TO
SEE.
AND WHEN IS IT ENOUGH?
WHERE IS AOC BY THE WAY?
REMEMBER WHEN SHE WAS CRYING
DOWN AT THE SOUTHERN BORDER
DURING THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
ABOUT ALL THE KIDS?
WHERE IS SHE NOW?
I KNOW SHE WAS BUSY AT AT THE ME
GALA FLAUNTING AROUND IN THAT
VERY FANCY DRESS OF HERS.
WHY IS THERE NOT MORE OUTRAGE
FROM THE FOLKS ON THE LEFT ABOUT
WHAT IS HAPPENING AT OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER?
ESPECIALLY TO THESE KIDS?
2 MILLION THAT WE KNOW OF LAST
MONTH ALONE.
IF YOU EXTRAPOLATE THAT
2.4 MILLION PEOPLE ILLEGALLY IN
AMERICA THAT WE HAVE DOCUMENTED
AT THIS POINT.
THINK ABOUT ALL THOSE PEOPLE
THAT COME OVER.
WE NEVER KNOW ABOUT GUYS.
BRIAN: ALL RIGHT.
LARA TRUMP, THANKS SO MUCH.
APPRECIATE IT.
AINSLEY: THANKS, LARA.
>> THANKS, GUYS.
BRIAN: AUGUST TO AUGUST A YEAR